vous téléchargez l'application les hits
rock bruce r non seulement vous est ce
qu'ils ont mais aussi à voter donc en
gros il faut que tout le monde l'est une
fois que vous avez téléchargé cette
application le retenait reviendra dans
votre région alors entre le 7 et le 10
août à sainte marie pour installer le
truc à la place tahrir c'est à jean
philippe
on va faire la fête on va avoir plein de
trucs allez venez venez ça va être super
génial et vous allez rentrer dans le
container en fait qui transformé en
studio d'enregistrement
vous allez avoir un casier vaut toutes
les conditions du studio reçoit mont
lacq l'image le super sont les autos
vous entrez dans le conteneur ou d'un
truc vous allez avoir l'impression aux
étoiles sont gênés soit new york ça va
être pareil il faut que vous êtes fermez
là dedans avec my magic vous chantez et
après pour passer à la télé en enfer
spectacle et puis disons environ aux
deux mois plus tard vous allez faire une
demi-finale martini départissent pas de
demi finale et puis une grande finale
qui va désigner des gagnants qui
partiront à paris faire une grande
finale on va dire mondiale puisque
ceux-ci se passe sur tous les continents
pour la martinique la guadeloupe la
guyane
la réunion et mayotte et voilà et vous
serez certainement nous on est
certainement la martinique ce que
certainement le guen au second coco
parce que il n'y a pas de raison on a
toujours démenti sic
dans le cas les finales de tous les gros
concours de chants nationaux que ça soit
la nouvelle star que ça soit vu comme
star académie à des propos pop star donc
ya pas de gas oil & gas on y va et on va
tout déchirer
ok tu vous rendez vous rappelle les
dates alors les dates c'est du 7 au 10 à
7 marie et puis à la fin du mois à fort
de france
sinon on est on sera sur le tour des
yoles on sera sur le tour des yoles vous
pourrez approcher les hôtesses que vous
expliquer comment aussi vous vous
inscrire sur le truc et on vous donne
rendez-vous à fort de france vendredi et
samedi pour les deux dernières étapes
pour le troc sur reste allez vous pouvez
venir le voir
vous pouvez venir samedi et dimanche
samedi et dimanche vous pouvez venir le
voit où il admiré et pourquoi garder
accroissant ce studio qui va accueillir
tous les candidats au travers la
martinique pendant le mois d'août
l'événement culturel de la vente unique
du mois d'août secte roch